[Music]
wet hair
rock hard abs in that black mesh catsuit
jlo sizzled during her ama duet with
maluma
from the costume to the lighting to the
chair it seems she was channeling
beyonce's iconic performance at the 2014
grammys
the other big duet justin bieber and
shawn mendes
they performed the song they co-wrote to
monster shutting down rumors they had a
feud of her bieber's wife haley
who sean briefly dated back in 2018.
another headliner
the weeknd but why was his face covered
in bandages
the singer who won three awards took
over a bridge in downtown l.a and filled
it with fireworks
and yes he's okay those face bandages
are to draw attention to the dangers of
drunk driving
the theme of his video blinding lights
meanwhile katy perry performed for the
first time since becoming a mom
[Music]
and taylor swift one artist of the year
look what you made me do
the reason i'm not there tonight is i'm
actually re-recording all of my old
music in
the studio where um where we originally
recorded it so it's been amazing and i
can't wait for it to hear it
as for how they pulled this award show
together
[Music]
bibi brexa who performed with joja cat
told us the amas followed strict coveted
protocols
how different and difficult was it for
you to get rehearsal time together
it was difficult it was constant testing
and uh
you know we you would go into the
rehearsal space and then it was
every 45 minutes it had to be aired out
for 15 minutes and clean
so you'd be in the middle of rehearsals
and everybody would be aired out and you
have to have your masks on but it's
worth it
last year's host sierra who presented
says the pandemic has forced her to up
her game
i kind of feel like you have no choice
but to really be creative because you're
like
in the same four walls every day i'm
thankful for
the time i could spend with my family i
think i've just realized what's
what's important in life and it's put
everything in perspective so i think at
the end of the day
my kids are really the only thing that
matters
when it came to the ama fashion the big
trend of the night was silver and lots
of leg
bibi rocked a slit cara delevingne was
glam and dolce gabbana
paris hilton paired her plunging mini
with a pony and short hair don't care
j-lo brought the heat and custom balm on
yes baby host taranji p henson also hit
the carpet in the color of the
night before changing it to 12 different
outfits during the three hour show
it's machine gun kelly megan fox
introduced her man at five months
machine gun kelly after the pair made
their official red carpet debut
favorite pop song winner jualifa gave us
an under the sea moment in her secret
starfish versace mini before changing
into a short blue number for her
sky-high performance from london
it was surreal it was so surreal i felt
like i was in
uh cirque du soleil and the american
music new artist of the year award goes
to
doja cats doji had picked up two awards
and gave us a
not so safer work look she's already
getting grammy buzz and broke this news
to each
other i'll be just excited to perform
like that's that's my number one but if
we win something that's that'll be
crazy so is that already a den deal your
performance for the grammys
you will be performing oh i don't know
many of the stars we saw shine at the
amas could come up big
at the grammys so the nominations will
be announced tomorrow
at noon eastern and we'll be streaming
it on et live
and at etlive.com